This is 99% infosible. I'm Roman Mars. In a world known as the 1990s, Chancellor Hanz was a skinny kid in Dallas, the new kid at school, and he loved going to the movies. Yeah, Grew up in Dallas. Favorite past time was to go to the movies. That's literally all I ever did. I mean, if I had a nothing to do Saturday, which was often, I would see at least three or four movies a day, for sure. I think I was nine or 10 when I knew I wanted to work
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。在被称为20世纪90年代的世界里，钱塞勒·汉兹（Chancellor Hanz）是达拉斯一个瘦弱的孩子，他是学校里的插班生，而且他酷爱看电影。是的，我在达拉斯长大。我最喜欢的消遣就是去看电影。那真的是我唯一做过的事。我的意思是，如果周六我没事做，而这种情况经常发生，我肯定一天至少会看三到四部电影。我想我九岁或十岁时就知道我想在电影院工作了。
at a movie theater, but I couldn't actually do it until I was like, I don't know, 14 or 15s when they start letting people have jobs. Chancellor became a projectionist, which if you love movies is a dream job. When new prints came in, Chancellor would watch them all the way through for hiccups and errors, staying late alone in the auditorium.
但我直到14或15岁左右，也就是人们开始可以打工的年纪，才真正实现这个愿望。钱塞勒成为了一名放映员，如果你热爱电影，这绝对是一份梦寐以求的工作。当新的胶片拷贝送来时，钱塞勒会把它们从头到尾看一遍，检查有没有跳帧或错误，独自在放映厅里待到很晚。
But what he really loved was to see movies with other people. So he would go back to work on his days off and watch the same movies over again with a crowd. The more packed, the better. May and Fridays and Saturday nights were my favorite. Can you please tell me where your brother's hiding? Why do you want him? Because your only brother can prove I'm not a killer. You don't know any of the people in that room, but you're all on a common ground of how hilarious
但他真正热爱的是和别人一起看电影。所以他会在休息日回到工作岗位，和观众一起重温同样的电影。场次越满越好。周五和周六晚上是我最喜欢的。你能告诉我你哥哥躲在哪里吗？你找他干什么？因为只有你哥哥能证明我不是杀人凶手。你并不认识那个房间里的任何人，但你们在“这一幕太搞笑了”或者“这一幕太吓人了”、“看成龙跳过梯子太酷了”这些感受上有着共同点。你知道我的意思吗？天哪，我只是去看电影。就像大家达成了一致。你不认识那个人，但你坐在那里和他们一起欢笑，度过一段美好的时光。90年代初的电影院，通常并没有那么好。
the scene is or how scary the scene is, how awesome it is to see Jackie Chan jump through a ladder. You know what I mean? Oh my god, I'm just going to the movies. It's like everybody is on one accord. You don't know that person, but you're sitting there laughing with them and having a good time. Theaters in the early 90s, they weren't usually all that nice.
（续上）90年代初的电影院，通常并没有那么好。
And Chancellors was no exception. The auditoriums were cramped and narrow. The screening was dumb. It was a very tiny, semi-ragony theater, but in the raggedy way that's endearing, where it's like the sounds coming from one speaker. But one day, Chancellor heard about a new kind of theater, on the other side of town. This is reporter Ryan Kyloth with the story of this intriguing new theater. Chancellor jumped in the car and drove downtown and then passed downtown.
钱塞勒的电影院也不例外。放映厅又挤又窄。放映效果很差。那是一个非常小、破破烂烂的电影院，但那种破烂感又让人觉得亲切，就像声音只从一个扬声器里传出来一样。但有一天，钱塞勒听说城另一头有一家新式电影院。这是记者瑞安·凯洛斯（Ryan Kyloth）带来的关于这家引人入胜的新电影院的报道。钱塞勒跳上车，开车穿过市中心，然后继续向前。
Passed the business district, passed the hospitals, passed the strip malls with the car dealerships, and finally down one of those long empty roads that seems to anticipate suburbs that don't exist yet. You can see it from the highway. You know how a Walmart or a Sam's Club looks from the freeway? No one ever says they can't find it. So, yeah, first time pulling up to that, it's just like, wow, like you feel like,
经过商业区，经过医院，经过有汽车经销商的露天购物中心，最后沿着一条长长空旷的道路行驶，这条路似乎在期待着尚未建成的郊区。你在高速公路上就能看到它。你知道沃尔玛或山姆会员店从高速公路上看是什么样子吗？没人会说他们找不到。所以，是的，第一次开车到那里，感觉就像，哇，你会有那种感觉，
especially growing up in Dallas when you're not around like Hollywood stuff and anything. That's like the closest you get to like Hollywood. It's like a cinema theme park and they made it feel like that all throughout. Chancellor could not believe how much better this theater was than the one where he worked. In fact, he would get off of work at his job
特别是在达拉斯长大，周围没有好莱坞之类的东西。那就像是你离好莱坞最近的地方。它就像一个电影主题公园，而且他们让整个地方都充满了这种感觉。钱塞勒简直不敢相信这家电影院比他工作的那个好那么多。事实上，他会从自己工作的地方下班，
where he saw movies for free and drive 40 minutes across town to pay for movies at this new place. It was like, oh, this is what's going on. Like, what are we not doing this at the other place? What Chancellor had discovered there in the suburban sprawl of Dallas was the AMC Grand 24. Built in 1995, it was the first of its kind. The first movie Megaplex in the US. You know the kind, the gigantic neon big box stores of movie going. They're kind of easy to dismiss as sort of a tacky 90s invention, but Megaplexes and specifically this one in Dallas, upended the entire theater business and even changed the kinds of movies that got made in ways you might not imagine. The rise of the Megaplexes pretty recent, but it's part of a pattern.
在那里他可以免费看电影，但他宁愿开车40分钟穿过全城，去这个新地方花钱看电影。当时的感觉就是，哦，原来这才是电影院该有的样子。为什么我们在原来的地方不这样做呢？钱塞勒在达拉斯郊区的蔓延地带发现的正是AMC Grand 24。它建于1995年，是同类电影院中的第一家。这是美国第一个电影“超级影院”（Megaplex）。你知道那种类型，巨大的霓虹灯大盒子电影商店。人们很容易把它们看作是90年代一种俗气的发明，但超级影院，特别是达拉斯的这一家，颠覆了整个电影院行业，甚至以你可能无法想象的方式改变了电影的制作类型。超级影院的兴起虽然很近，但它是一种模式的一部分。
The kinds of movies we watch has always been tied up with how we watch them. And where? The peak of movie going in this country was the 1940s when there really wasn't another game in town. Besides, I don't know, newsfavors? Comic books? The old ballgame? And then, television came along.
我们观看电影的类型总是与我们观看它们的方式紧密相连。还有地点？这个国家电影业的巅峰是20世纪40年代，当时城里真的没有别的娱乐活动了。除了，我不知道，新闻短片？漫画书？老式棒球比赛？然后，电视出现了。
The TV dinner fifties. As television kept viewers at home, movies competed by becoming more spectacular. The 1960s was the era of huge studio ethics. I'm Spartacus. I'm Spartacus. I'm Spartacus. And the theater has got bigger and more luxurious as well. To see a movie at the time was to have an usher in a tuxedo, hand you a printed program
电视晚餐的五十年代。随着电视把观众留在了家里，电影通过变得更加壮观来竞争。60年代是大型制片厂史诗片的时代。“我是斯巴达克斯。”“我是斯巴达克斯。”“我是斯巴达克斯。”电影院也变得越来越大、越来越豪华。当时看电影意味着会有穿燕尾服的引座员递给你一份印刷好的节目单，
before guiding you to your seat. Well, yeah, I started out as an usher and you never left the auditorium. So whatever movie was playing, you knew every line, every inflection that the director intended. You got to know movies pretty well. Ted Mundorf's first job was at a single-screen movie palace in the San Francisco suburbs in 1969. Yeah, we had, I want to say, somewhere between 1200 and 1700 seats. So it was huge. It was like you wouldn't even find anything like that today.
然后引导你入座。嗯，是的，我最初是一名引座员，你从不离开放映厅。所以无论放映什么电影，你都知道每一句台词，导演意图的每一个语调。你对电影了解得很透彻。泰德·蒙多夫（Ted Mundorf）的第一份工作是1969年在旧金山郊区的一家单厅电影宫。是的，我们有，我想说，大约在1200到1700个座位之间。所以它非常大。就像你今天根本找不到那样的电影院了。
Every movie was a spectacle that couldn't be recreated anywhere else. Back then, studios and theaters had a business arrangement, where if a theater had a certain movie, nobody else in the area could play it. Seeing a film was kind of like seeing a painting or a Broadway show. It lived at one particular location, and you had to go there. If you lived in the suburbs, you had to get in a car or get on the train and you had to go up to San Francisco to see the first run movie. And then afterwards, the movies would play later in the suburbs. In the early 70s, this began to change. Studios realized there was enough demand to release
每一部电影都是一种在其他任何地方都无法重现的奇观。那时，制片厂和电影院有一种商业安排，如果一家电影院放映某部电影，该地区的其他人就不能放映。看电影就像看一幅画或一场百老汇演出。它只在一个特定的地点存在，你必须去那里。如果你住在郊区，你必须开车或坐火车去旧金山看首轮电影。然后之后，电影才会晚些时候在郊区放映。70年代初，这种情况开始改变。制片厂意识到有足够的需求来同时在郊区和城市发行
movies in the suburbs and the city simultaneously. But with just a single screen in most theaters playing two movies meant half as many show times for each one, which led to the next logical step, creating more screens. You had the single screens, and then you had the cutting up of the single screens. So you had these terrible configurations, these bowling alley type auditoriums that resulted from the slicing up of existing movie theaters.
电影。但大多数电影院只有一个放映厅，放映两部电影意味着每部电影的场次减半，这导致了下一个合乎逻辑的步骤：增加放映厅。你有了单厅，然后你有了对单厅的切割。所以你有了这些糟糕的布局，这些保龄球馆式的放映厅，这是对现有电影院进行切割的结果。
Ted Mundorf's enormous single screen was carved into two, and then four long, narrow auditoriums. And here and there, some little four and six plexus were built, now that there were enough films to sustain them. But as movie going became a less exclusive experience, it became a less exclusive experience. No more tuxedos. As the 70s rolled into the 80s, theaters went from swanky to sticky. Any coke that ever spilled there is still there today. And this cramped, grungy, sort of top floor of the mall movie experience was keeping people away. Ticket sales dropped 15% in the mid-80s.
泰德·蒙多夫巨大的单厅被分割成两个，然后是四个又长又窄的放映厅。到处都建了一些小型的四厅和六厅影院，因为现在有足够的电影来维持它们了。但随着看电影变成了一种不那么独特的体验，它也变得不那么排他了。不再有燕尾服了。随着70年代进入80年代，电影院从时髦变得黏糊糊的。任何曾经洒在那里的可乐至今仍在那里。这种拥挤、肮脏、位于购物中心顶层的电影体验让人们望而却步。80年代中期，门票销售额下降了15%。
Meanwhile, home video was taking off, so people were staying home with their televisions again. And the industry took notice. Theater owners knew the whole experience needed an upgrade. If people were going to go to the movies less, we need to make it a knockout experience every time. Enter Stand Our Wood. Back in the 60s, Stan had taken over the family business, a little Kansas City chain called Derwood Theoders, and carved up their big screens to show more films.
与此同时，家庭录像带开始兴起，所以人们又回到了电视机前。行业注意到了这一点。电影院老板知道整个体验需要升级。如果人们去看电影的次数减少了，我们需要让每一次体验都成为一种震撼的体验。斯坦·德伍德（Stan Durwood）登场了。早在60年代，斯坦就接管了家族企业，一个名为“德伍德影院”（Durwood Theaters）的小型堪萨斯城连锁店，并分割了他们的大厅以放映更多的电影。
By the 80s, he'd built a few dinky little fourplexes, and eventually he changed the name of his company to American multi-cinema, AMC. Stan was known in the industry as a rule breaker and provocateur. He was larger than life. That was a long pause. He was a complex man. Norr Dashwood worked for Stan at AMC for 22 years. And she says he identified the problems in the industry before anyone else.
到了80年代，他已经建造了一些破旧的小型四厅影院，最终他将公司名称改为“美国多厅影院”（American Multi-Cinema），即AMC。斯坦在业内以打破常规和挑衅者而闻名。他是一个传奇人物。（停顿）他是一个复杂的人。诺拉·达什伍德（Nora Dashwood）在AMC为斯坦工作了22年。她说他在任何人之前就发现了行业的问题。
He realized upgrading theaters and offering people more choices was the only way forward. He'd been to Belgium and seen a huge cinema with 25 screens. So he comes back from this trip. He says, this is the future. This is what we have to do. The finance team ran the numbers and said, no, this is a terrible idea. You will never sell enough tickets and popcorn to afford this thing. Increase rents, increase construction cost, and it just didn't work. The math didn't work.
他意识到升级电影院并为人们提供更多选择是唯一的出路。他去过比利时，看到了一家拥有25个放映厅的巨大电影院。所以他从这次旅行回来后说，这就是未来。这就是我们必须做的。财务团队计算了数字后说，不，这是一个糟糕的主意。你永远卖不出足够的电影票和爆米花来负担这个东西。租金增加，建筑成本增加，这根本行不通。数学上算不过来。
Standurwood did not care. He bet the company on megaplexes. The AMC grand would be first, but before it even opened, 30 other megaplex deals were locked. Contract signed, ground being broken. When he got an idea, that idea got materialized. What would have happened if the bet had not paid off?
斯坦·德伍德根本不在乎。他把公司押在了超级影院上。AMC Grand将是第一家，但在它开业之前，其他30个超级影院的交易就已经锁定了。合同已签，破土动工。当他有了想法，那个想法就会变成现实。如果赌注没有成功会发生什么？
A.M.C. would have gone bankrupt. Nora was there in Dallas for the Grand Opening VIP party, and she says the energy at the event was nervous. it was there in Dallas for the grand opening VIP party and she says the energy at the event was nervous. It was like, okay, you built it. Now is anyone gonna come? Oh, they came. In fact, they clocked out at their jobs at other movie theaters and came.
AMC会破产。诺拉当时在达拉斯参加盛大的开业贵宾派对，她说活动现场的气氛很紧张。就像是，好吧，你把它建起来了。现在会有人来吗？哦，他们来了。事实上，他们从其他电影院下班后就赶来了。
Walking in always put a smile on my face because they go all out posters and banners and standees. That's Chancellor Haynes again, who used to drive to the grand from his job across town. This place was everything his theater wasn't. It was brand new. The seats had new car smell. There were arcade games, neon, everything, multiple concession stands, enormous displays and props, and then there were the auditoriums themselves, 24 of them. The screens were massive.
走进去总是让我脸上露出笑容，因为他们全力以赴，海报、横幅和立牌应有尽有。那是钱塞勒·汉兹，他过去常从城另一头的工作地点开车去Grand影院。这个地方拥有他原来工作的电影院所没有的一切。它是全新的。座位上有新车的味道。有街机游戏、霓虹灯、一切，多个特许经营摊位，巨大的展示和道具，还有放映厅本身，足足有24个。屏幕非常巨大。
Even the smaller theaters had bigger screens than the theaters that I was used to. Tinsler wasn't the only person going out of their way to get to this theater. I know there were six of us that went six guys. We all piled into like an 84 Thunderbird. I can remember that more than 20 years later, Kevin Morris still remembers the first time he went to the AMC Grand 24. It was a well over an hour drive. Was it worth it? Oh, yeah. Well, for me, it was because I actually got a seat. It was packed.
即使是较小的放映厅，屏幕也比我习惯的电影院要大。钱塞勒并不是唯一一个不远万里来到这家电影院的人。我知道我们有六个人去了，六个家伙。我们都挤进了一辆84年的雷鸟（Thunderbird）。我记得那件事，20多年后，凯文·莫里斯（Kevin Morris）仍然记得他第一次去AMC Grand 24的情景。那是一段超过一小时的车程。值得吗？哦，是的。对我来说，因为我真的抢到了座位。那里挤满了人。
I mean, it was there was a lot of people there and at two o'clock in the morning, if you can believe that for a movie. EMC expected the grand to attract 800,000 visitors in its first year. They got three million. By this point, Ted Mundorf, the guy who used to work as an usher back in the 60s, was film buyer at a theater company in LA. Naturally, he kept an eye on the competition. He says the theater industry is unusual in this way, because...
我的意思是，那里人山人海，而且是在凌晨两点，如果你能相信的话，那是一场电影。AMC预计Grand影院第一年将吸引80万游客。结果他们吸引了300万。到这个时候，泰德·蒙多夫，那个60年代做过引座员的人，已经是洛杉矶一家电影公司的购片人了。自然，他密切关注着竞争对手。他说电影院行业在这一点上很不寻常，因为……
We share our numbers. So if you're running a movie theater in Los Angeles, you can see the numbers, the box office, results of an individual theater in Dallas, Texas. Out of curiosity, how were you getting those reports? Were those emails? Was it too early, were you getting faxes? Oh, no, these were delivered hand-delivered to you.
我们分享我们的数据。所以如果你在洛杉矶经营一家电影院，你可以看到德克萨斯州达拉斯一家独立电影院的票房结果。出于好奇，你是怎么得到这些报告的？是电子邮件吗？那时候太早了吗，你是通过传真收到的？哦，不，这些是人工送到你手上的。
Big chunks of paper, like a newspaper, except thicker, and they were delivered on a daily basis to the offices. Ted would glance through these box office reports with his morning coffee and he noticed that this one theater in Dallas was just going gangbusters. So you're seeing these numbers about the AMC grand that are just insane than what? Then we put a bunch of people on the plane and flew down the luxury theater. Refreshments are available in the lobby. And please, keep our theater clean by disposing of trash and specify containers. Enjoy the show.
一大叠纸，像报纸一样，只是更厚，每天送到办公室。泰德会一边喝着早咖啡一边浏览这些票房报告，他注意到达拉斯的这家电影院简直是火爆异常。所以你看到关于AMC Grand的这些数字简直疯狂，然后呢？然后我们派了一群人坐飞机飞过去看这家豪华电影院。大厅提供茶点。请通过将垃圾丢弃在指定的容器中来保持我们的电影院清洁。享受电影吧。
What Ted's team saw in Dallas, it wasn't just the big screens and big sound, or the on-spiring lobby. There was something else springing people to the AMC Grand. Stadium seating. Staggering seating on risers, steep risers all the way up to the rafters, like a Roman Coliseum. We're used to this now, but at the time it was revolutionary. Before the AMC Grand theaters had floors that were just ever so slightly sloped.
泰德的团队在达拉斯看到的，不仅仅是大屏幕和大音响，或者是令人敬畏的大厅。还有别的东西吸引着人们来到AMC Grand。体育场式座位（Stadium seating）。在阶梯上错落有致的座位，陡峭的阶梯一直延伸到天花板，就像罗马斗兽场一样。我们现在习惯了这一点，但在当时它是革命性的。在AMC Grand之前，电影院的地板只是稍微倾斜一点。
If you got the wrong person in front of you, the movie was ruined. With stadium seating, every seat had an unobstructed view. Someone's wearing a hat in front of you? Didn't matter. Someone was 6'10 in front of you? Didn't matter. You were high enough above them that you could see the screen. Ted knew exactly what he had to do. Back in Los Angeles,
如果你前面坐错了人，电影就毁了。有了体育场式座位，每个座位都有无遮挡的视野。有人在你前面戴着帽子？没关系。有人在你前面有6英尺10英寸高？没关系。你坐在他们上方足够高的地方，可以看到屏幕。泰德确切地知道他必须做什么。回到洛杉矶，
his company was about to start construction on a new theater. I mean, plans were done on this particular project and been approved by the city of Los Angeles, we were about to start breaking ground and we immediately halted it. We knew at that point that stadium's seating once the direction you had to go in, if you were gonna build new theaters. Ted's intuition was right, as Megaplexes went up all over the country, that theaters around them collapsed.
他的公司正准备开始建造一家新电影院。我的意思是，这个特定项目的计划已经完成并得到了洛杉矶市的批准，我们正准备破土动工，但我们立即停止了。我们当时就知道，如果你要建造新的电影院，体育场式座位就是你必须走的方向。泰德的直觉是对的，随着超级影院在全国各地拔地而起，周围的电影院纷纷倒闭。
So it was like a nuclear bomb in that, when that thing opened, you could draw this circular ring around it and all the slope floor regular movie theaters around it lost anywhere from 40 to 80% of their business overnight overnight One by one theater companies rushed to get in on the Megaplex trend and took on a ton of debt trying to build these things. Were there people who said, eh, seems like a fat, I'm not going to bother. One of the largest companies in the country that was their attitude.
所以就像一颗原子弹一样，当那个东西开业时，你可以在它周围画一个圆圈，周围所有斜坡地板的普通电影院一夜之间失去了40%到80%的业务。一夜之间。电影公司一个接一个地争先恐后地加入超级影院的潮流，并背负了巨额债务试图建造这些东西。有没有人说，呃，这看起来像是一阵风，我才不折腾呢？全国最大的公司之一就是这种态度。
The president actually told me as he was building a theater, said, we don't believe in stadium seating theaters. And what happened to them? They went bankrupt. The business has grown to 26,000 screens across the country, even at a time when video rentals and cable channels keep some fans at home. Megaplex has seemed to pull moviegoers back to the big screen. Kelly O'Donnell NBC News Los Angeles.
总裁在建造电影院时实际上告诉我，说，我们不相信体育场式座位的电影院。结果他们怎么样了？他们破产了。这个行业在全国范围内已经发展到26000个放映厅，即使在视频租赁和有线频道让一些影迷留在家里的时候也是如此。超级影院似乎把电影观众拉回了大银幕。凯利·奥唐奈（Kelly O'Donnell），NBC新闻，洛杉矶。
That report was from early 1996, just a few months after the grand opened. Within six years, the number of movie screens in the US increased by 50 percent in six years. And this is where you really begin to see the architecture influencing the art. Because these new movie palaces didn't just pull movie goers to the screen. They pulled movies to the screen. When there's more screens to play, then you essentially need more content to play on them. Ben Fritz is an editor at the Wall Street Journal and wrote a book about the 21st century movie business.
那篇报道是在1996年初，就在Grand影院开业几个月后。在六年内，美国的电影放映厅数量增加了50%。这就是你真正开始看到建筑影响艺术的地方。因为这些新的电影宫殿不仅把电影观众拉向屏幕。它们也把电影拉向了屏幕。当有更多的屏幕可以放映时，你本质上就需要更多的内容来放映。本·弗里茨（Ben Fritz）是《华尔街日报》的编辑，写了一本关于21世纪电影业的书。
He says between the rise of DVDs and all this new screen real estate, film studios cranked their production up to 11. And films got more varied as well. A larger share of them started coming from original ideas instead of sequels or remakes or adaptations. All the movie studios will always start with the safest bets. They'll always start with the safest bets. They'll always start with Home Alone 3. But eventually they run out of those, right? And then they still need to make more. Then they're going to have to, they have their forced to just take bets on that weird original spec script that's been sitting around that everybody thought was kind of cool
他说，在DVD的兴起和所有这些新的屏幕空间之间，电影制片厂将产量调到了11级。电影也变得更加多样化。其中更大比例的电影开始来自原创想法，而不是续集、翻拍或改编。所有的电影制片厂总是会从最稳妥的选择开始。他们总是会从最稳妥的选择开始。他们总是会从《小鬼当家3》开始。但最终他们会用完这些，对吧？然后他们仍然需要制作更多。然后他们将被迫去押注那个一直放在那里、每个人都觉得有点酷的奇怪原创剧本，
but nobody really wanted to take a risk of making. For the first time in a long time, the major studios were throwing money at new ideas and new directors. In the flavor of movies, the type of which used to live only in small art house theaters started getting wider release. Jack Foley was a distributor at Miramax. That's the person who sells movies from the studios to the theater owners. He distributed films like Pulp Fiction and Train Spotting.
但没人真的想冒风险去制作它。长期以来，主要制片厂第一次向新的想法和新的导演投入资金。电影的风格，那种过去只存在于小型艺术电影院的类型，开始得到更广泛的发行。杰克·福利（Jack Foley）是米拉麦克斯（Miramax）的发行商。那是把电影从制片厂卖给电影院老板的人。他发行了像《低俗小说》和《猜火车》这样的电影。
I'm not writing a museum. I want this to be a business, and you want this to play out to the masses. You want to corrupt the youth of America. Foley says the Megaplex was a Trojan horse for slipping strange, subversive movies into unsuspecting suburbs across America. If the latest teen movie was sold out, kids might end up seeing... Melchovitch, Melchovitch, Melchovitch. Melchovitch, Melchovitch.
我不是在经营博物馆。我希望这是一个生意，你希望这能面向大众。你想腐蚀美国的年轻人。福利说，超级影院是一匹特洛伊木马，可以将奇怪、颠覆性的电影悄悄带入美国各地毫无防备的郊区。如果最新的青少年电影卖光了，孩子们最终可能会去看……《成为约翰·马尔科维奇》（Being John Malkovich）。
Melchovitch. Being John Melchovitch for your information got into 630 theaters at the widest. That was a pretty good break because being John Melchovitch was on the border of Incomprehensible, I used to say to Charlie Kaufman, hey, next time make your film linear. Yeah, I mean, I remember walking out
《成为约翰·马尔科维奇》供你参考，在最广泛的时候进入了630家电影院。那是一个相当不错的突破，因为《成为约翰·马尔科维奇》处于不可理解的边缘，我过去常对查理·考夫曼（Charlie Kaufman）说，嘿，下次让你的电影线性一点。是的，我的意思是，我记得走出
of being John Melchavitch in theaters, going, what the hell was that? The New Jersey Tour of Pike. What about me seeing you seeing me seeing you in court? Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, John Malkovich came out in 1999, a year that lots of people call one of the best movie years ever. Can you just rattle off for me as many movies from 1999 as you can name from memory? Absolutely. Okay, so Fight Club, the Matrix, Office Space, Three Kings, Election, The Sixth Sense, The
《成为约翰·马尔科维奇》的电影院时，心想，那到底是什么鬼东西？新泽西收费公路。关于我看到你看到我看到你在法庭上？哈哈哈哈……《成为约翰·马尔科维奇》于1999年上映，这一年被很多人称为有史以来最好的电影年份之一。你能为我列举出你能从记忆中想起的1999年的尽可能多的电影吗？当然。好的，那么《搏击俱乐部》、《黑客帝国》、《办公空间》、《夺金三王》、《选举》、《第六感》、《女巫布莱尔》、《诺丁山》，布莱恩·拉夫特里（Bryan Raftry）实际上写了一本关于1999年的书。叫《有史以来最好的电影年份》。你有《成为约翰·马尔科维奇》，你有《大开眼戒》，你有《钢铁巨人》，《男孩别哭》，《处女自杀》，《伴郎》。那是第一波。还有《美丽比基尼》、《啦啦队长》、《美国电影》、《美国派》。《罗拉快跑》。
Blitter Witch Project, Notting Hill, and Bryan Raftry actually wrote a book about 1999. Called Best Movie Year Ever. You have being John Malcolm, you have eyes wide shut, you have the iron giant, boys don't cry, the version suicides, the best man. That's like the first wave. Drop dead gorgeous, but I'm a cheerleader. American movie, American pie. Run low, LaRun, go.
（续上）《天才瑞普利》、《颠倒乾坤》、《被禁锢的女孩》。还有更多。不仅所有这些伟大的电影都被制作出来了，它们还找到了观众。你可以走进一家超级影院说，好吧，这里不仅有14部电影在放映，而且有14种不同类型的电影在放映，我现在想看哪一种？
The talented Mr. Ripley, Topsy Turvy, Girl in Arrupted. There are so many more. Not only did all these great movies get made, they found an audience. You could go into a megaplex and say, okay, there's not just 14 movies playing it, there's 14 different kinds of movies playing it, and which one am I in the mood for right now?
（续上）但这个有趣的、不寻常的、原创电影的小黄金时代，并没有持续太久。在90年代末感觉如何？感觉泡沫即将破裂吗？嗯，我们在结构上知道我们有麻烦了。超级影院的建设热潮如此迅速和猛烈，以至于现在电影院太多了，没人再想要那些陈旧破烂的了，但那些建筑的租金仍然要付。所以你有所有这些旧电影院，这就是导致破产的原因。对于破产，我想有12起。
But this mini golden age of interesting, unusual, original films, it didn't last that long. Did it feel like in the late 90s? Did it feel like a bursting of a bubble was coming? Well, we knew structurally we were in trouble. The Megaplex building craze had been so fast and furious that now there were just too many theaters and nobody wanted the old dingy ones anymore, but there was still rent to pay on those buildings. So you had all these old theaters and that's what caused the bankruptcy. For bankruptcy's, I think there were 12 of them.
好莱坞刚刚度过了一个创纪录的假日周末，似乎正朝着创纪录的一年迈进。但具有讽刺意味的是，今年关闭的电影放映厅将比开业的还要多。随着电影院泡沫开始破裂，创意泡沫也随之破裂。随着屏幕减少，冒险的理由也减少了。关于，你知道，一个关于通往约翰·马尔科维奇大脑的门户的奇怪故事。展览商意识到，他们不必在许多不同的屏幕上放映各种不同的电影，而是可以在一半的屏幕上放映一部像《加勒比海盗》这样的大片，每20分钟开始一场新的放映。
Hollywood is coming off a record holiday weekend and appears to be headed for a record year. But ironically, more movie screens will close this year than open. As the theater bubble began to pop, the creative one did too. With fewer screens, there were fewer reasons to take chances. On, you know, a weird story about a portal into the brain of John Malkovich. Instead of showing all different kinds of movies on lots of different screens, exhibitors realize that they could just play one blockbuster like Pirates of the Caribbean on half the screens, with a new show starting every 20 minutes.
它所做的是，它对首映周末产生了巨大的关注。制片厂喜欢让大片广泛上映，尽可能多地在屏幕上开画。这样他们就可以赚取现金，并吹嘘票房历史上最好的首映周末，这将产生更多的头条新闻、炒作和业务。
What it did is it created this huge attention to opening weekend. Studios love to break blockbusters wide, opening on as many screens as possible. That way they could break in the cash and brag about the best opening weekend in box office history, which would generate more headlines and buds and business.
所以如果你是一个购片人，你会接到发行商的电话说，嘿，你要上映《蝙蝠侠》或者《珍珠港》或者不管是什么。我想要两个屏幕。我想要三个屏幕。我想要四个屏幕。有时这些是有条件的。换句话说，除非你能保证《珍珠港》有四个屏幕，否则你拿不到这部电影。
So if you're a film buyer, you get a call from the distributor and say, hey, you're opening Batman or you're opening Pearl Harbor or you're opening whatever it is. I want two screens. I want three screens. I want four screens. And sometimes those were conditional. In other words, you weren't going to get the movie unless you could guarantee four screens on Pearl Harbor.
随着大片占据了越来越多的屏幕。较小的独立电影被挤了出去。有一段时间，蓬勃发展的DVD销售为拥有小众观众的古怪电影提供了另一个平台。但随着DVD在2000年代后期消失，主要制片厂越来越依赖他们的大型特许经营大片，这就是为什么现在每一部新电影都是另一部《蜘蛛侠》续集
As Blackbusters took up more and more screens. Smaller indie movies got squeezed out. For a while, booming DVD sales provided another platform for Oddball movies with a niche audience. But as DVDs disappeared later in the Outs, the major studios leaned more and more on their big franchise, Blackbusters, which is why every new movie these days is another Spider-Man sequel
或者《速度与激情25》。很难想象现在还能回到过去，你知道，我认为电影院已经几乎完全变成了这些大预算特许经营电影的地方。你在多大程度上觉得商业模式真的是开启或关闭创造力的阀门？我认为有时人们回顾过去说，哦，有一种文化运动让美国人在90年代对独立电影感兴趣，或者文化中发生了什么让我们想看。
or Fast and the furious 25. What's hard to imagine that's coming back from now is that, you know, I think movie theaters have become a place very much almost exclusively for these big budget franchise films. To what extent do you feel like really it's the business model that is the valve that turns the creativity on or off. I think sometimes people look back and say, oh, there was there was some kind of cultural movement that made made Americans were interested in indie films in the 90s, for example, or something was happening in the culture that we wanted to see.
（续上）从2010年开始的漫威特许经营电影。不，真正的解释是电影业的经济状况在那段时间发生了变化。那改变了制片厂制作电影的类型。现在，电影业的经济状况正在发生更剧烈的变化。电影院公司在新冠疫情之前就已经陷入困境。随着人们转向Netflix，拥有越来越多的可供狂欢的内容，上座率正在下降。在疫情期间，该行业一直在进行一场现实生活中的实验。
It's got a Marvel franchise films starting in 2010. No, it's really the explanation is that the economics of the movie business changed in that time. And that changed the types of the movie business changed in that time, and that changed the types of movies the studios were making. Now, the economics of the movie business are changing even more radically. Theater companies were in trouble even before COVID. Attendance was dropping, as people turned to Netflix with more and more bingeable content. During the pandemic, the industry has been living out a real-life experiment.
人们多年来一直想知道，但从未测试过。当新电影直接进入流媒体，或者同时在电影院和家里上映时会发生什么？如果我们能像在家里一样轻松地获得它们，哪些电影会让我们去电影院？电影越容易获得，它就越危险。泰德·蒙多夫认为大型动作大片仍然会吸引人们出门。但剧情片、喜剧片和奇怪的小艺术电影
People have wondered about for years, but never tested. What happens when new movies go straight to streaming, or release simultaneously in theaters and at home? If we can get them just as easily at home, which movies will get us to go out to theaters? To swallow the film, the more endangered it is. Ted Munnor thinks the big action blockbusters will still get people out. But the dramas and comedies and weird little art films
可能会被降级到你的电视上。也许到今年夏天，我们可以安全地回到电影院，制片厂可以开始收集关于哪些类型的电影仍然有能力吸引我们出门的数据。在此期间，如果你只需要一点点修复，如果你只是想记住和一群人一起看电影是什么感觉，让我推荐YouTube上这些在“以前”录制的观众反应视频。有一个是某人在电影院里拍摄的，当时一群非常热情的观众正在观看
might be relegated to your TV. Maybe by this summer we can safely go back to theaters and studios can start to gather data on what kinds of movies still have the power to pull us out. In the meantime, if you need just a little fix, if you just want to remember what it's even like to see a movie with a bunch of people, let me recommend these audience reaction videos on YouTube recorded in the before times. There's one that someone filmed in a movie theater as a very passionate audience was watching
《复仇者联盟：终局之战》。在电影结尾的这一幕中，有一场大战，看起来所有的希望都破灭了，但慢慢地，整个漫威宇宙的所有英雄一个接一个地前来救援。观众简直疯狂了。这段视频让我想起了一种我几乎忘记的在拥挤的电影院看电影的感觉。这确实是你无法替代的东西。超级影院、艺术电影院、带服务员的全躺式躺椅、某些艺术画廊后面的折叠椅，这都不重要。
Avengers Endgame. In this scene towards the end of the movie, there's this one big battle where it looks like all hope is lost, but slowly all the heroes of the entire Marvel Universe come to the rescue, one by one. And the audience just goes wild. This clip reminds me of a feeling that I've almost forgotten about watching movies and a packed theater. It truly is something you just can't replace. Megaplex, Arthouse, full lie down recliners with the Wader service, fold out chairs in the back of some Art Gallery, it doesn't matter.
我只想坐在一个黑暗的房间里，面对一面明亮的墙，和一群陌生人一起为同样的东西欢呼。“我们不会让你走的！我们不会让你走的！”斯派克·琼斯（Spike Jones）和昆汀·塔伦蒂诺（Quentin Tarantino）并不是90年代唯一试图成名的电影制作人。还有一群杂牌牙医。休息后回来。所以我回到了瑞安·凯洛夫（Ryan Kyleoff）关于那个故事的报道，在那个故事中，你采访了一个我们无法完全融入我们讲述的故事的角色，但他真的让你着迷。所以让我们听听其中的一些。
I just want to sit in a dark room with a bright wall, and cheer at the same stuff with a bunch of strangers. We won't let you go! We won't let you go! Spike Jones and Quentin Tarantino weren't the only filmmakers trying to make it big back in the 90s. There was also a motley gang of dentists after the break. So I'm back with Ryan Kyle off the report of that story and there was a character that you interviewed for the story that we couldn't quite fit into the tail that we were telling, but really fascinated you. So let's hear some of that.
是的，这是整个超级影院兴衰传奇的一个小片段。我在整个过程中交谈过的我最喜欢的人之一。所以我们刚刚经历的超级影院的故事，对吧？这是一项新的技术发明，为所有这些新电影的放映打开了空间，并让各种新类型的电影传播到美国各地。有趣、不寻常的电影。但它们并不全是《成为约翰·马尔科维奇》、《搏击俱乐部》和《黑客帝国》。这种电影制作的繁荣也创造了一些其他类型的电影，我们可以这样说。不是那么独立的经典。
Yeah, it's a little sub piece of this whole Megaplex rise and fall saga. One of my favorite people that I talk to throughout this thing. So the story of the Megaplex that we just went through, right? It's this new technological invention that opened up room for all these new movies to be shown and new kinds of movies spreading across America. Interesting unusual ones. But they weren't all being John Malchovic and Fight Club and the Matrix. This boom in movie making also created some other kinds of movies, shall we say. Not so indie classics.
完全正确，完全正确。因为这是一场电影制作的淘金热。所以很多人进入了电影制作行业，包括一群由这个家伙领导的牙医，这相当出名。我叫吉姆·克莱斯勒（Jim Chrysler）。我住在伊利诺伊州的森林湖。好的，那么他的故事是什么？在90年代中期的某个时候，他住在中西部，你知道，用他的话说，在“周二的战争”中战斗。一天晚上，他和他的朋友
Exactly, exactly. Because this was a gold rush of movie making. So lots of people got into the movie making business, including somewhat famously a group of dentists led by this guy. My name is Jim Chrysler. I live in like Forest Illinois. Okay, so what's his story? At some point in the mid 90s, he is living in the Midwest, you know, in his words, fighting the war on Tuesday day. And one night he and his friend
决定开车去芝加哥参加他们听说过的一个慈善拍卖会。所以他们去了。碰巧那天晚上，公牛队有一场季后赛。慈善拍卖会空无一人。就像吉姆和他的朋友以及其他三个人在这个
decided to drive into Chicago for this charity auction that they'd heard about. So they go. And it just so happens that that night, the bulls have a playoff game. And the charity auction is empty. It's like Jim and his friend and like three other guys in this
巨大的酒店宴会厅里，吉姆以极低的价格赢得了大奖之一。这是他妻子在某部在现场观众面前拍摄的电视节目中的一个客串角色。“你不想逃离吗？有时你想去我去的地方。”天哪，那将是梦想成真。我想我们应该对那些很年轻或者可能没有Netflix的人说，那是《干杯酒吧》（Cheers）的主题曲。那是《干杯酒吧》的主题曲。
giant hotel ballroom and Jim gets one of the grand prizes for a steal. It is a walk-on part for his wife in a certain TV show that's filmed in front of a live studio audience. Wouldn't you like to get away? Sometimes you wanna go where I'm going. Oh my goodness, that would be a dream come true. I guess we should say for people who are quite young or maybe don't have Netflix, that is the theme song to Cheers. That is the theme song to Cheers.
所以发生了这种情况，几个月后，吉姆和他的妻子飞往洛杉矶，来到拍摄《干杯酒吧》的派拉蒙地块，吉姆得以坐在现场观众席的看台上。而我的妻子得以坐在吧台。她见到了明星，结果泰德·丹森（Ted Danson）刚刚做了根管治疗。她说，嗯，我丈夫是牙髓病专家。你有问题吗？他说，我确实有。她说，嗯，我丈夫是牙髓病专家，所以你有问题。他说，我确实有。所以她向我招手，让我到吧台区。
So this happens, like a few months later, Jim and his wife fly out to LA to the Paramount lot where cheers is filmed, Jim gets to sit in the bleachers in the live studio audience. And my wife got to sit at the bar. She got to meet the stars and it turned out that Ted Danson had just had a root canal. And she said, well, my husband's in End of Donuts. Are you having a problem? He says, I am actually. And she said, well, my husband's in end of Donna, so you're having a problem. He says, I am actually. So she's waves to me down to the bar area.
我站在那里，把手指伸进泰德·丹森的嘴里。太不可思议了。就像吉姆度过了最美好的夜晚。所以他在休息后非常准备好，当他在观众席中遇到的这个家伙后来坐到他身边说，嘿，伙计，你是一位成功的牙髓病专家。你有没有想过制作电影？我觉得这是有史以来最酷的事情，非常天真。
I say I ain't there sticking my finger in Ted Danson's mouth. So incredible. Like Jim is having the best night. So he is then very primed after the break for when this guy he'd met in the audience, sitals up to him later and says, like, hey, man, you're a successful endodontist. You ever think about producing movies? And I thought this was the coolest thing ever, very naive.
这确实就像羔羊被带去屠宰一样。所以他遇到的这个家伙向他介绍了制作电影的基础知识，你需要多少钱以及涉及的工作，吉姆回到中西部，开始四处筹钱。嗯，我当时已经执业15年了，我有几百个有很多钱的朋友，那是牙科的黄金时代，这些人都在40多岁。一个是骨科医生，一个是全科牙医，另一个是正畸医生。是的，所以这群杂牌军把他们的钱凑在一起，他们制作了一部名为
And it truly was just like lambs being lent to a slaughter. So this guy that he met talks him through the basics of producing movies and how much money you need and the work involved and Jim goes back home to the Midwest and starts passing the hat around. Well, I just, I was in practice for 15 years at that point and I had hundreds of friends who had a lot of money and there was a golden age of dentistry and these guys were in their 40s. One was an orthopedic surgeon, one was a general dentist, another was an orthodontist. Yes, so this Motley crew puts their money together and they make a movie called
《发烧湖》（Fever Lake）的电影。哦，我要去看它。它是……请不要。我很抱歉，吉姆。你看过吗？“史蒂夫，快点！”我很抱歉，吉姆。你看过吗？“史蒂夫，快点！快点！史蒂夫，我不认为这有什么帮助。”所以这看起来像是一种典型的林中小屋、杀手类型的电影。是的。
Fever Lake. Oh, I'm going to watch it. It's the app please don't. I'm so sorry Jim. Did you watch it? Steve, hurry! So sorry Jim. Did you watch it? Steve, hurry! Hurry up! Steve, I don't think it helped much. So this seems like a kind of typical cabin in the woods, slasher type movie. Yes.
我们雇佣了马里奥·洛佩兹（Mario Lopez），他当时正从《救命下课铃》（Saved by the Bell）中走出来。他正在寻找事情做。科里·海姆（Cory Hame），正处于康复期之间。马里奥实际上成了我的好朋友。这些年来我失去了与他的联系，但我相信如果我遇到他，我们会重温很多回忆。
We hired Mario Lopez, who was that thing which is coming off, saved by the bell. And he was looking for something to do. Cory Hame, who was between rehab. And Mario became a good friend of mine, actually. I've lost touch with him over the years, but I'm sure we would rekindle a lot of memories if I ran across him.
如果他显然不是一个巨大的热门，但它得到了很多宣传。所以我们不配得到那种宣传，但在当时，由威斯康星州的牙医组成的独立制作公司非常少。我们在市中心举行了盛大的首映式，它上了头条。所以吉姆对宣传感到高兴。他得到了，他得到了。
If he were like not a huge hit, obviously, but it got a lot of publicity. So we didn't deserve that kind of publicity, but at the time there were very few independent production companies made out of dentists from Wisconsin. We had a big premier downtown, it made the front page. And so Jim's happy for the publicity and all. He gets it, he gets it.
人们认为他们是牙医很可爱，等等。但他也有限度。《华尔街日报》特别每天来找我一次。它说，嗯，我们在你的办公室采访你，我们就坐在你的牙科椅旁，手里拿着雪茄。我说，绝对不行。我说，你知道，我是一个……我很抱歉。你知道，我宁愿不做那篇文章。我喜欢他为自己挺身而出。
People think it's cute that they're dentists, et cetera. But also he had his limits. The Wall Street Journal in particular came to me once a day. It said, well, we'll interview you in your office and we just sit by your dental chair with a cigar in your hand. I said, absolutely not. I said, you know, I'm a bug that I'm sorry. You know, I rather not do the article. I like that he stood up for himself.
我喜欢他在沙滩上划了一条线说，你知道，你可以玩得开心，但我不会参与到这个程度。但这太棒了。好吧，为他高兴。而且《发烧湖》赚钱了。但它太糟糕了，以至于成了邪典。人们注意到了它，它不会花费我们那么多钱，所以我们从中获利颇丰。问题是，这有点像去拉斯维加斯第一次赢钱。因为这些人就像，太棒了，让我们继续吧。所以他们继续制作电影，他们成了牙医制作公司，飞来飞去
I like that he drew a line in the sand and said, you know, like, you can have your fun but I will not participate in it to this extent. But that's great. Well, good for him. And Fever Lake made money. But it was so bad, it was colty. People picked up on it and it wouldn't cost usik made money. It was so bad. It was culty and people picked up on it.
我一天做根管治疗，第二天出去制作电影。并非每部电影都做得那么好，但吉姆说他们没有在任何一部电影上赔钱。所以是的，吉姆此时对自己感觉相当不错。“你以为你在和谁打交道，宝贝？”你知道在那个时候。我……我已经成为了好莱坞的牙科大亨。然而，在21世纪初，就在这个超级影院泡沫破裂时，坦率地说，整个行业发生了很大变化，吉姆发现事情更难驾驭了。所以他从电影业休息了很长时间，只专注于日常工作。
And it wouldn't cost us that much money, so we got out of it pretty well. The problem was, it's a bit like going to Vegas and winning for the first time. Because these guys were like, great, let's keep going. So they kept making movies, and they became the dentist production company flying back and forth
对。虽然在过去几年里，吉姆又回到了这个行业，最近他的一部电影在苏格兰获得了英国电影学院奖（BAFTA）最佳剧情片奖。有趣的是，我想在你告诉我这个故事之前，我会认为参与制作电影简直是一场灾难。但现在我有点像，嘿，也许我应该……
I'm doing a real canals one day and going out and doing producing a movie the next day Not every film did as well But Jim says they didn't lose money on a single film. So yeah, Jim's feeling pretty good about himself at this point Who do you think you're dealing with here, baby? You know at that point. I was I Have become this dental mogul in Hollywood. Then though in the early 2000s, just as this megaplex bubble is bursting, and frankly, a lot is changing in the whole industry, Jim found things harder to navigate. So he took a long break from the movie industry and just focused on the day job.
我有时在做真正的牙科手术，第二天又去制作电影。并非每部电影都表现出色，但吉姆说他们没有一部电影亏钱。所以，是的，吉姆此时对自己感觉相当不错。你以为你在和谁打交道，宝贝？你知道在那一点上，我已经成为了好莱坞的牙科大亨。然而，在21世纪初，就在大型影院泡沫破裂时，坦率地说，整个行业发生了很大变化，吉姆发现事情变得更难处理了。因此，他从电影业休息了很长一段时间，只专注于日常工作。
Right. Although in the past several years Jim is back at it, recently one of his movies won a BAFTA for Best Feature in Scotland. The funny thing is, I think before you told me this story, I would think it's just a disaster to get involved in producing movies. But now I'm kinda like, hey, maybe I should
没错。虽然在过去几年里吉姆又重操旧业，最近他的一部电影还获得了苏格兰英国电影学院奖的最佳故事片奖。有趣的是，我想在你告诉我这个故事之前，我会认为参与电影制作简直是一场灾难。但现在我有点觉得，嘿，也许我应该试试。
get into producing movies, but now I'm kind of like, hey, maybe I should get into producing movies. Well, thanks Ryan, this is really fun. Yeah, I'm so glad we got to tell Jim's story. 99% of visible was produced this week by Ryan Kyloff, edited by Katie Mingle, mixed by Amita Ganatra, music by our director of Sound, Sean Riel. The Laney Hall is a senior producer, Kurt Colstedt is the digital director, the rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Johnson, Abby Madon, Chris Baroube, Vivian Le, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Charles Ackland at Concordia University for his help and time on this story.
开始制作电影，但现在我有点觉得，嘿，也许我应该开始制作电影了。好的，谢谢瑞安，这真的很有趣。是的，我很高兴我们能讲述吉姆的故事。《99%无形》本周由瑞安·凯洛夫制作，凯蒂·明格尔剪辑，阿米塔·加纳特拉混音，音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里尔制作。莱尼·霍尔是高级制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特是数字总监，团队其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、艾比·马登、克里斯·巴鲁贝、薇薇安·勒、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢康考迪亚大学的查尔斯·阿克兰为这个故事提供的帮助和时间。
His book Screen Traffic was a great resource. Thanks also to Bill Bynowski, Dan Jinks, Michael Schaumburg, and Sharon Waxman. We are a project of 91.7 K.L.W. in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Discover, listen, and support them all at radiotopia.fm.
他的书《银幕流量》是一个很好的资源。还要感谢比尔·比诺夫斯基、丹·金克斯、迈克尔·沙姆堡和莎伦·瓦克斯曼。我们是旧金山91.7 K.L.W.的一个项目，在广播街制作。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的集合。请访问radiotopia.fm发现、收听并支持他们。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me, at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Orc, on Instagram and Reddit too. But we have every episode of 99% invisible plane on over 400 screens at 99PI.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@Roman Mars，关注节目@99PI Orc，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上关注。我们在99PI.org上有超过400个屏幕播放《99%无形》的每一集。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。